I came into this video playing turbo
tortilla from Finland until we get a
French by transposition let's see how
the exchange a welcome sight in the
morning not the most thrilling a line
maybe I can get some sort of imbalance
with 96 aha here we go here's the
imbalance try for night f 52 to get the
bishops and this is cute is just
ignoring this okay now if I take
oh come on oh okay no I want to say
let's have some fun but ok on g5 he
might play night x g5 and he's having
all the fun let's not do that
hmm
gavotte ich his Queen he's got queen age
five quite quite annoying ah come on I
want to play some crazy movie back for
you tempted this threatens g5 age for
winning this piece and I'll rupee one I
go King f7 probably it's it's complete
crap but I don't know I felt like
playing something crazy but do I need to
move the King I what about Bishop e7 as
this a bad move probably not done then
why not actually
now you can play the check here yeah I
was thinking that this is actually
helping me King it's not bet on g7 at
all
mmm this don't look too bad g3 is a very
useful weakness to attack
not sure even how he protects it King
edge to this H for King f2 looks really
good least range I mean strange maybe
you need to but ok it's making a
sacrifice out of it probably what I
would have done as well looks too crazy
to to protect it so g-form yeah let's
just play G form that asks this night
where do you go now night h 2 26 is
really embarrassing losing the night and
you only have squares like you want yeah
this loses the night I hope no way to
protect it
so is there an some attacking idea and
not an f5 is the sensitive square but
the bishop p.m. really does a good job
covering age form so there's no real
threat of night age for coming
just look yahoo h6 looks a bit strange
but what about this isn't this good yeah
I think so as long as he's not able to
put the night to h5 it's it's all fine I
to age four and a five I want to play
rookie a rookie to this is my IDM using
the e-file and 97 is also good to 97 g6
and form yeah this is some the way I
should I should go
so is there some direct way probably I
need to I need to use the night as well
just AM 96 f form
and now nitey to a rookie to as a quite
dangerous five enough time you play some
strengthening moose
you have no way to prevent Queenie to
light design yeah with no counter play
at all yeah I probably I played I played
a somewhat crazy opening so this problem
is some way to refute it this is still
okay I mean no no problem this also but
here this age 53 sets probably probably
a bit much black and simply play Bishop
e7 and castles with no a big problem but
h5 is really risky check
yeah after this may be okay I was more
worried about let's say C for something
some aggressive move not sure if it is
working but it's it's looking dangerous
and maybe I can't even take and really
play that yeah then d5 I know it looks
very very very dangerous it's so open
this position there's probably some way
to refute it and this I'm not so sure
about and this check is definitely a
mistake we should do six yes this helps
like enormously oh the compass is giving
black and win and here already after
that yeah it's losing so many moves it's
just checking and going back and all the
way King to do seven it's just great and
now you cannot you cannot cover this and
g4 winning yeah simply what I are
supposed to do where this one I can I
can evening or just take but also hear
this these nights are simply if that
it's completely tied up I need to do
something aggressive him like like c4 or
maybe the compounds to play on Knight to
c3 here Knight c3 after g5 sacrificing
or with the bishop even yeah interesting
there are many interesting possibilities
but h3 was a bit too lame alright thanks
for watching